so this is Ajax and I've trained him to
help me find penis he's the only Kia dog
in the country and I guess that means
the world people are really shocked when
you tell them that there are riskier
than there are Kiwis I've been training
Ajax since he was a pup he walks around
the forest all day with me he hops and
the helicopters he comes on boats
we've been caving
[Music]
yeah he comes everywhere with me
[Music]
he's got a good keen nose and he's able
to let me know if there's a Kia close by
or if there's one still in the hole
he'll it'll indicate by standing there
quite awkwardly with his nose directly
in the hole
[Music]
it's really sad we need when you come
across the Kia nice that you've been
monitoring and watching the the chicks
grow and and all of a sudden you get
there and they're gone and you know they
haven't flesh because it's too early and
you know they've been provided by some
piece get you down because you you think
about that happening you know on
hundreds of kidneys every year all
across the South Island it does make you
think you know can we win this battle
[Music]
boy good boy good boy there's a perfect
indication there's the piece you've done
I want people just to look at key users
and important species that we have here
in the South Island of New Zealand and I
want stories like this with about me and
Age X to make people aware and family
and special they are
[Music]
working to conserve an endangered
species it's really rewarding every
day's an adventure it's helping the
world my little corner of the globe
[Music]
leave it
[Music]
[Music]